Today we're going to look at Egyptian fractions
and by that I do mean the ancient Egyptians. They
worked base 10, like we do. So they had symbols;
and I'm going to attempt to draw some hieroglyphs.
So their symbol for the number 1 is this
- groundbreaking - it's called a single stroke.
So if they wanted to say 2, they combine two of
these. Um for 10 in hieroglyphs they have this
which I believe is called a cattle hobble, which I
think was used- you maybe put it around cattle legs
to slow them down. I looked into it, don't really
know what that does, but this is a 10 which is
a far more interesting use of it. For 100 - and now
I'm almost definitely going to get this the wrong
way around - but I think it's this way and it's a
coil of rope. I'm pretty sure it's that way round,
someone will correct me if it's not. For 1,000 this
is when it gets slightly more complicated, and I've
got to use my art GCSE; it is the water lily. For
10,000, a bent finger, that looks vaguely like this,
and that's a bent finger. Okay, bent finger. 100,000?
Obviously whenever I think of 100,000 what I think
of is tadpoles; so this is a tadpole. And now
finally a million, and this really is going to be
putting my art skills to use. A million is Heh. Now Heh
is the personification of eternity or infinity. So
a million also kind of just means an eternal or
infinite amount, which isn't actually unheard of
in cultures that we have things like this. Umm
some people believe that 1,001 Arabian nights
actually is meant to mean infinity and a bit more.
So the idea of there being a very large number,
meaning that number or infinity, is actually not
an uncommon idea at all. So these are the Egyptian
hieroglyphs for powers of 10; and if you wanted to,
maybe say you wanted to write I don't know 23, what
you would do is you would write two 10s and a 3.
And you just combine them like that. So now on
to fractions; um I'm going to be talking about - I'm
getting technical here - earlier Egyptian fractions.
So there is actually evidence that fractions were
done slightly different later on, there's a famous
Papyrus called the Rhind Mathemathical Papyrus.
What we're going to be talking about is earlier
um when fractions were all done by having a mouth
symbol like this and then a number underneath. So
you might say this, and what this would be is
a tenth, because it's the mouth symbol over 10. Now
with this we can only get numbers- fractions with
1 in the numerator. In fact there are only two
exceptions um to this; so we can have 2/3, which
is like this, and then there is also 3/4 and a
half for some reason is different. But aside from
that, all others are of the form 1 / n. So it begs
a question, how is this useful? What happens if we
have another another fraction? What happens if we
have say 5/6? Well 5/6 is going to be just a
1/2 plus a 1/3, so actually we can still do
this. Now with Egyptian fractions, which is what
these are called, all the denominators have to be
different. Should we try another one? 15/36 is going
to be a 1/3 is 12/36, and that leaves 3/36 which is
equal to a 1/12. So so far looks like we can do it.
The question is, can we always do it? So for this
I want to introduce you to the greedy algorithm.
We've got our fraction p over q, and we're going
to say p is not 1 - because we know if p is 1
we can do it, we'll just write it as is. And the
greedy algorithm looks at the largest 1/n such
that 1/n is less than p/q. And we start by just
taking away this 1/n. What do we know about this?
This is going to be positive, because we know this
is less than this. So we'll end up with pn - q
over qn which is positive, okay? We can actually
write an expression for n as well, we could write
n is the ceiling function of q over p, so it means
it's the smallest integer above this fraction. Ah!
We haven't actually used the fact that 1/n is
the greatest for which this is true. Cos what this
means is that p/q is also going to be less than
1/(n-1). So we've said that this is going to be
the smallest such n or the largest such 1/n,
they're the same thing, that's less than this, hence
we have this inequality too. Now from this we can
multiply this out and then we get that for example
p times (n-1) is less than q. And if we substitute this
in we get that pn - q is strictly less than
p - and we already know it's positive remember. So
we've started with p/q, we've taken away 1/n,
and now we've ended up with a new fraction,
we'll call it p1/q1 such that p1 is less
than p. Now if p1 is 1 we're done, because then
we could just say that p/q is 1/n plus p1/q1.
And if p1 is 1 we're done. If not, we just
repeat this process. So we can then say that, okay
let's find the largest such 1/n, the smallest
n, that we get p1/q1 it's greater than 1
over let's call it n1 and less than this - and we
just repeat. And then we'll end up with p1/q1
take 1/ n1 = p2/q2. And again we'll have, okay,
that 0 is less than p2 is less than p1. We can
substitute back in, get p over q is 1/n + 1/n1.
Plus then this will be p2/q2. And again if
p2 is 1 we're done - if not we repeat it again.
So this is why it's called an algorithm, it's
a series of steps. And what we're going to end
up having is 0 is less than pr for some r is
less than - and it just keeps going - less than p. But
these are all integers, these are all positive
numbers. We can't have it going down infinitely,
one of these is eventually- we're going to have to
hit 1. And the way we've constructed these qs
they're all going to be different as well. Hence
this process is eventually going to terminate.
But yeah eventually we're going to get a pr that
equals 1, so we're going to have p/q is
1/n + 1/n1 plus plus 1 over...then qr. And we're going
to be done. So eventually this process does stop,
so this greedy algorithm means that there is
always an Egyptian fraction. Okay, there's one final
cool thing that I want to share with you. Because
here you remember we we used a greedy algorithm
where we took the biggest 1/n so n was n was
this value. Now if we slightly change this, if we
slightly cheat, and instead use the n is q/p
+ 1 - and I'm going to show you this for 1. So 1
equals- well here q/p, it's 1 over 1. So
q/p is going to be 1 + 1 is 2, so that's a
half. And then what we're going to do with our half,
this is our new p/q. So q/p, 2 over 1 is
2, 2 over 1 + 1 is 3. So it's a 1/2 plus a 1/3.
What remains is 1/6. And we can keep following
this algorithm we get a 1/2 plus 1/3 plus- it'd be a
1/7 + 1/43 + .... and so on. This is the cool thing
as well, because here if at any point we truncate
it it gives the Egyptian fraction closest to
1 for that many that many terms. So 1/2  is
the Egyptian fraction with one term closest to
1. 1/2 plus 1/3 is the Egyptian fraction
with two terms closest to 1. 1/2 plus 1/3
plus 1/7 is the Egyptian fraction with three
terms closest to 1 - and I just think it's really cool.
I love that there are so many courses
on Brilliant and always new ones being added.
Look here, I've spotted this recent edition on
vectors; so, well, I thought I'd check it out. In
typical fashion it's quirky, well designed,
and super interactive. I'm not just watching,
I'm doing. All the courses, the quizzes, the content
on Brilliant is just like this - it's a great place
to learn. It doesn't feel like education it just-
it feels like fun, but I'm learning at the same
time. If you haven't already, you might want to
consider signing up and getting into all this
good stuff. Or perhaps give the gift of Brilliant
by signing up family and friends for the premium
subscription. What a great and unexpected
present. Wherever they are on their learning
journey, Brilliant has something for everyone - math,
science, computers; it's all covered. Now Brilliant
has a free 30-day trial so you can go and give
it a good go, and Numberphile viewers can get
a 20% discount on their subscription by going
to brilliant.org/Numberphile. That URL is there
on the screen and I'll also put a link in the
video description. Our thanks to Brilliant for
supporting Numberphile.
- So my favoritenumber changes a lot but for now it is 288.
You might be looking at that and thinking
'what's special about 288?' Don't worry, we'll
get there, but first we need to rewind a bit
and talk a bit about factorials. Specifically
super factorials. Now I know regular Numberphile
viewers will have seen factorials before...